ça aurait pu être la sortie de vos
vacances de pâques mais il faudra encore
patienter avant de découvrir les quatre
nouvelles attractions de family park
installé entre monts et souris ni le
parc a dû reporter son ouverture à cause
des mesures gouvernementales pour le
couple de gérants cela commence à faire
long
d'autant que chaque saison ce sont 60 à
80 emplois qui sont créés sur place
hélène chapelet la grande roue de family
park elle n'a pas tourné depuis sept
mois et dans les allées pour l'instant
aucun cri d'enfant
la réouverture de ce parc d'attractions
prévu pour les vacances de pâques n'est
plus d'actualité à cause du confinement
pourtant son propriétaire garde
confiance en l'avenir
la preuve il vient de faire
l'acquisition de nouvelles attractions
cette année 2021 on ne renonce pas aux
investissements on a voulu faire plaisir
à nos clients nous avons acheté quatre
nouvelles attractions dont celle ci
c'est un grand bras articulé qui monte à
15 mètres de hauteur équivalant jeu
gauche de gauche à droite une nouvelle
attraction à sensation que les employées
montrent maintenant depuis une semaine
et l'idée c'est aussi de faire plaisir
aux ados et aux adultes en mal de
sensations fortes un public jusqu alors
un peu délaissé avec seulement deux mois
d'activité en 2020 à cause du
confinement
le propriétaire compte sur 2021 et ses
nouveaux manèges pour retrouver une
fréquentation plus conformes aux
prévisions
chaque jour une fois minimum de 350 300
350 personnes afin qu'on puisse rentrer
dans les frais vu le nombre de sérié et
vu les dépenses que l'on a fait est que
l'on fait toujours voilà
l'investissement des manèges c'est
énorme
l'entretien les manèges c'est énorme les
frais fixes
donc il nous faut 300 350 personnes par
jour des visiteurs que bon bein le lama
attend également avec impatience
tout comme ses compagnons de la
mini-ferme patrick quant à lui croise
les doigts pour une réouverture avant
les vacances d'été